tick tock has of course been in the news
a lot lately as i'm sure you know
you've seen do you think that
tick tock will be banned i don't even
know i've been taking a break from tick
tock so i haven't been on it
as much i think i post like the last
month i posted like two videos
but yeah i have no idea when it comes to
that
why did you take a break from tick tock
um all the hate got overwhelming
i had to spend time away from reading
comments
watching hate videos on me it really
took a toll on me
and i just wanted to better myself by
excluding social media why
why do you think you are getting so much
hate and what do you want people to know
i'm just like a teenager
that is still growing and learning and
like they're all watching me so there
are going to be times where i do make
mistakes
and people are very hard when it comes
to that
and no matter how sincere or sorry that
i can be
i'm still going to get criticized for
everything that i do which is hard
but um i learned that in the hard way
will you be
sad for tick tock if it goes away
i i don't even know anymore
it's just gotten so toxic recently that
i really wouldn't mind but
i mean i'd be a little upset considering
that's where i started
so um i have to get credit for that way
but
i i feel like you have been so affected
because you keep talking about like
the comments and that it's gotten so
toxic for you
why do you think it's become such a dark
place i don't know if people
are bored because of quarantine or
just i can't really explain it because
some of the things that i
see said about me or other people it's
like i could never say that
to anyone so i can't really wrap my head
around it but
um it happens and it sucks and
you just have to deal with it but i hope
it changes
how how do you deal with it i noticed on
instagram
i was bummed because you posted this
really cute picture and i wanted to go
and i wanted to comment on it it was
like you in the yellow
um hoodie and i went to comment and it
was like comments have been disabled
so why did you make that decision i just
think for my mental health
i realized that reading those comments
and seeing those comments just wasn't
healthy
and i decided to just cut it off
and take a step back so it has affected
your mental health though
yeah i mean i've struggled with it for a
while but it has
um made things worse and has really hurt
me
i'm also like relatively like new to
this
so it was just a lot of different
changes in my life
all at once and then i had to deal with
all the hate um with everything
and it got to me so there was like a
point where like i
like had deleted all of my apps and
would only like
re-download them to post and then as
soon as my stuff was posted i delete
them again
so i wouldn't have to look at all the
comments any dms like nothing
wow is it like
anxiety is it depression and what
i mean what do we do to help
you i don't feel like anybody should
feel that way um
yeah i mean i've been dealing with like
mental illness for like ever since i was
little
so um it's like been like an ongoing
thing
and a lot of people on social media
don't realize that i'm human and that
a lot of creators are human and have
real struggles and so
when they just see us as a person on the
screen
they don't really care about our
feelings which i feel like a lot of
people have to take that
into account and realize that before
they type something
and send it because it is harmful but
yeah
when when you say you've been struggling
not to get too personal i'm just like
curious about your story and i think it
will help people to know your story
um when you say you've been struggling
with mental illness what types of mental
illness um i had generalized anxiety
disorder and bipolar too
so um yeah when did you
get diagnosed for those things um
i've been in therapy for anxiety since i
was like six
um and then um
when i was about
14 i was diagnosed misdiagnosed with
depression and then i
recently have been diagnosed with
bipolar 2.
how do you live with that and what do
you want people to know about
that i mean like behind the scenes i
try a lot to take care of my mental
health and make sure that i'm
stable and doing things like if i need
help i get it a lot of people don't
really notice that
but yeah i just really hope that people
realize they're like how much their
words
affect someone because essentially they
are cyberbullying
and no matter if you are already dealing
with a mental illness or not
it's gonna get to you especially if
you're being cyberbullied by millions
it's intense and it's scary it really is
i i want a second that because it is
cyberbullying anytime that you are
attacking somebody
online people need to learn that words
hurt and that you can't do that
what does hard day look for you when
you're having like a bipolar
episode well recently it's been a lot
better because i have
gotten um help but there were days where
like i could not get out of bed i'd cry
all day
couldn't really talk to anyone like i
just shut my phone off
um and like i wouldn't eat so
it just like gets like that and it gets
scary like your head just goes in a
bunch of different places
so you have to i just had to sleep like
all day and turn my phone off
i'm so sorry to hear that you've been
going through this
do you feel like tick tock has
intensified or like worsened
things because of all the eyeballs on
you
i mean like i've been dealing with it
before social media but then
um as i got
more hate and more criticism
and like like you said like more eyes on
me
um it really did take a toll and
it just added a lot more stress
um on everything and it got hard
but i'm working through it and i'm
[Music]
i know we talked a lot about the
hardships of fame and social media
is there a good side to it that you
think though
of course i mean i feel like i wouldn't
be able to come out with my song
a few days ago if i didn't have the
platform that i did and it's crazy
because like i dreamt about
singing and the platform that i like
when i was little that's all i wanted to
do
so the platform that i was able to
create on tick-tock
and instagram and all of that um
really led the way for that and i'm so
grateful
and i have the best supporters and the
best fan base and i could never be
more thankful for them than i am
you